now HSBC UK swoop for Silicon Valley
Bank UK which is bought for one pound
was held this week as a major boost for
the UK's Tech sector and startups more
broadly the alternative of svb UK
becoming insolvent had raised fears for
Tech and Life Sciences companies who
risked being deprived of their Capital
but what does the future hold for those
businesses once the bank is owned by
HSBC or with me now I'm pleased to say
Ian Stewart he's chief executive of HSBC
UK Ian welcome to you thank you what
made you want to buy this Bank
well we're in this industry we we like
the tech sector
um we we were very active last year
we've had two large funds totaling 750
million pounds great take up by
customers but you know on on Friday I
did not think we would be buying another
bank come Sunday it was opportunistic
but it allows us I think to accelerate
our strategy by two or three years we
are very excited with what we've got
we've got really good people and I think
we've got actually a very good business
that's been well run in the UK so three
things we want to do we want to first of
all underpin the business because I
think that's important we've already put
2.2 billion of liquidity into the bank
give our customers confidence that we're
doing the right thing so deposits are
safe you've got the HSBC Bank behind
your deposits now so please don't worry
about deposits at the same point as soon
as we're through the underpin stage
which is hopefully a couple of weeks
again it's supporting the bank because a
lot of the info structure is still with
the parent in the U.S so we'll cut that
umbilical cord and put our own Machinery
in behind that and then it's quickly we
can get through that as we can we'll be
into growth mode so that's exciting part
give me a flavor of what it was like for
you last weekend I mean there were other
offers on the table why do you think you
went out
well we always thought it was a very
competitive situation and then right up
until I would say maybe 11 p.m on Sunday
I still thought we were in a competitive
situation
what we had decided and I think we got
to a decision internally around about 6
30 p.m on Sunday is that we we've done
about five hours of due diligence
detailed due diligence superb job on my
team to get that done
um did we see any black holes no but we
couldn't be absolutely sure so we
decided as a group that we would put
what we thought was our very best foot
forward no government support at no
point was an upper back on this this was
a a wanted transaction From hsbc's
perspective and as I said we agreed what
we thought was a fair transaction fair
price and we put that forward and um
thankfully at the end of the day that
was successful but I think it was the
speed and the liquidity we had at hand
to step in and do a very very clean
Transaction what about the quality of
the loan book I think it's got five and
a half billion pounds worth of loans
outstanding you you won't be looking to
call any of those in or change the terms
on which those loans were given well in
first thanks for the question because it
allows me to give our customers you know
Comfort we will not be calling in loans
it's quite interesting actually our
investment Bank colleagues really helped
us understand the loan book explained
um what the bulk of the loans were we
got comfortable with that really quickly
it's quite a short-term book
um there's bits that I have to say were
we were a little bit less sure of
because we just didn't have the time but
but by that point I mean we had a very
large Bank we just put it through
through our sort of model we thought we
can live with that and we made a
decision and carried on there was some
commentary among tech companies and
among the startup Community after the
Takeover that svb UK really understood
the needs of tech companies and startups
rather better than a Traditional Bank
like HSBC what would you say in response
to that well were in this sector it's a
sector we like so so that would be my
first response I think what we get from
this bank which I think is really really
important is we we get just more
expertise and I'm absolutely delighted
that Aaron Platts agreed to stay on his
CEO and we'll announce that more
formally later but I don't mind telling
that today and Aaron is a real driver on
this business and with the team that
she's assembled there I think we can
really accelerate our plans and take
that expertise and do other things with
it across what is a very much an
International Bank in HSBC now what
we've got you in obviously uh Credit
Suisse is in the eye of a storm right
now
do people really have anything to worry
about about contagion risk here in this
particular case
you can never say never but what I would
say Ian is that post the the financial
crisis
2008-2009 Bank banks in the UK on a very
different place and that's where you've
got to really congratulate good strong
regulation I know sometimes complain
about it but it's good and here we are
now we're in a safe place banks are very
well capitalized great liquidity pools I
I think it's very different from 2008.
good notes on which to end in good luck
with the integration thank you very much
about it thank you very much thank you